the couple that slays together stays  together  check out Justin Timberlake and Jessica  Biel showing off their hot beach bods  during their romantic Caribbean getaway  on Wednesday  Jessica flaunted her toned tush in a CD  black bikini while JT went shirtless and  sported stripes swim short it was so fun  last month marked the two lovebirds  fourth wedding anniversary and it looks  like JT and Jessica finally found some  time to celebrate the occasion by  relaxing at a tropical destination  seemingly kid-free the can't stop the  feeling singer seems to have no problem  bragging about his wife's sexy physique  oh yeah here's the Tennessee native  gushing over Jessica when he was  inducted into the Memphis Music Hall of  Fame last October  now listen she's not from here but she  built like she is  you